I go everywhere I mean I work in a
political show so I had gone the
political blogs oh yeah an important
show well I'm looking less important
less political should probably go on a
lot of like cat porn yeah there's a lot
of cat born
i watch all inform your work who have
you seen my work you've seen that I I
read I mean we I think we well I don't
know what you do I know you don't you
don't even have an internet connection
I'm working on it yeah well I mean I I
look at cnn.com it's kind of an
underground here he goes again
here he goes yeah and I also look at
Drudge Report calm Wow um he's a little
right-leaning but he has a lot of
headlines on it um sometimes I met a
filter you ever been there
yeah I've been a meta filter it's pretty
great it's pretty awesome yeah sometimes
when I really need inspiration and I'm
like there's nothing I go to big thing
calm so I get a free t-shirt or
something what is it I don't know what
are you getting wristbands
nice no but I think you know just most
current events II kind of I can't go
everywhere and I um I like to go
Wikipedia sore thing where you just go
oh yeah
Wikipedia I've kind of been spending a
lot of my strike time learning about the
weirdest things in Wikipedia were
unusual articles who's there
yeah I swear an unusual grammatical
articles it's just random articles yeah
it's like random crazy things here this
street name you know like the X X Y Z X
X Street and like San Francisco is what
yeah that's like the last name
alphabetical street name huh there's
another great one where it's an insect
and ant Mike goes and kills this
cockroach like goes into his brain kills
it and then controls his brain like he's
riding a car and drives this
around into like his lair where like he
brings his whole family in the cockroach
and they just like eat it from the
inside I was like the worst now the
other interesting fact you can look up
on the internet Laura Bush killed her
ex-boyfriend in a car accident that's
true dt82 that you should know that that
is a she lives in a town of like 4000
people
she runs a red light and she kills her
ex-boyfriend what are the odds of that
nobody knows that that is not true what
about the fact that um bush senior
killed Kennedy he's left-handed he was
in Dallas the day it all went down
that's crazy but Laura Bush writer there
often like big chunks of time in between
jobs as TV writer and it's always
nerve-racking but the fact I think that
it's like everybody is talking about it
I stopped is and there's no end at oh my
gosh it's very nerve-wracking it's very
difficult because you don't you have no
sense of when it's gonna end so it's not
even like I can you can get like a
regular job which right I should do to
pay bills but yeah I can't you know you
can't be why you could go back to work
in theory in a week you know but you we
might not be working for like you know
six months right well you might get a
job actually getting it I'm getting two
jobs which is true one of them is I'm
helping manage a dog store manage my
apartment building
oh it's crazy okay
I get to help out a dog walking you get
to but you know dogs get residuals and
what else would see are their job
seriously that's great at another retail
place my neighborhood see what well I
guess I shouldn't say that that's
demeaning because that would also it's
not demeaning yes just a different
industry which to me I think it's not
demeaning
no no no it's not asking if you like
dogs it's hard I feel like it's hard
telling an employee an employer like
what you're up to you and you're like oh
that's why you like only like you can
only attempt or whatever yeah but
because you're screwing them over but
it's hard to get a temp job it's not a
waitering job in the city is it's really
oh yeah it's really hard
listen to you is it wool no this my
restaurant I go to three times a day
there's at least two servings plus the
sommelier friends from other shows who
you hadn't seen in a long time and it
was sort of it was sorry networking is
the wrong word because that makes it
sound like not career networking but hey
nice to see you or people that you
presume in Facebook to put it in terms
the internet will understand but then
that quickly wore off as the day's
became weeks became months right and the
same people again and again it's always
the same people and now it's sort of
turned on the thing where when there's
people on your staff who don't pick it
everyone's like why weren't you at the
picket line yeah it's quickly turn to
that thing yeah and we have one friend
who says the sky in our sadboys because
well it's really cold we were all like
like yeah that's the year now that the
writers feels breaking no the Writers
Guild picketing it's sort of fun to
answer solidarity it is I love sitting
solid area and I love I for a while I
was signing off on all my email says hey
hey ho ho management can't write the
show ComEd and gore but now like a lot
of that is just kind of I don't know it
must be historically the nerdiest like
whitest union weakest weakest awesome
physically you would take one Pinkerton
to knock all of us down yeah with with
half a baton of like a nerf baton yeah
we'd like the threat of overtime I'm met
at the time not the time well the other
thing is we in New York have to pick it
in the winter and LA they're picking us
like beautiful outside it's like a
picnic everyone is getting really tan
they're yeah they're the best shape of
their lives
we are huddled we are the huddled masses
60 degree weather mo Lazarus was talking
about us we're just yearning to be
employed we so and then we also leaflet
we do leaflet that that's been actually
very interested interesting is leading
people in the street and sort of falling
back in every sales technique that you
ever came up with as a Girl Scout or
working in retail or whatever and just
being like trying to schmooze people and
just take
a leaflet yeah and then and then getting
sort of accusatory like do you watch
television and then and then the like
the please just please just take find
like looking people in the eye really
helps yeah walking backwards walking
backwards yeah I found the best thing
was to say free free information and if
you say free yeah so we'll take it and
then they meet you see the look on their
face where they've been tricked but I'd
like to put like a dollar bill and
actually hand it to them also and it's
not effective money that you've gotten
from scabbing well actually my wife is a
hedge fund so I'm just I'm doing better
than ever time here it's been great